tu vois le mentalisme c'est ça du coup
c'est de se dire est ce que moi j'avais
prévu à l'avance est-ce que c'est ton
intuition qui est très forte
ou est ce que beaucoup manière ou d'une
autre sicaud logiquement à choisir cette
carte là en particulier
salut ça fait bien longtemps qu'on n'a
pas parlé de mentalisme pure sur cette
chaîne et encore moins de tours de
mentalisme donc ça peut peut-être même
trop longtemps donc aujourd'hui je vais
vous montrer de trucs de mentalisme
super bluffant que vous allez pouvoir
refaire vous même lors des fêtes de noël
par exemple je trouvais que c'était la
bonne période
ou alors lors d'un dea en fait oui mais
là c'est plus la période de noël du coup
tu vas pas d'habiter ta grand-mère faire
des trucs un peu plus le fond est-il et
quand je rencontre quelqu'un ok ça ça
s'appelle une commande je l'inscris tu
vas nous faire en ce moment c'est qu'au
vide
donc c'est pas possible de rencontrer
des gens dans la lampe assez compliqué
ça ok mais tu peux apprendre un truc
dans la vraie vie
ok way est aussi un truc en vision
hockey jean report des dates en visio
aussi toi ok et bienfaisance la chaire
loïc l'influencent heures vous m'avez
influence est donc logique
[Musique]
pour vous l'avez compris donc
aujourd'hui je vous montre deux tours
que vous pouvez faire n'importe quand
mais principalement ils ont été pensés
pour être fait lors d'un deuil tu que ce
soit dans la vraie vie ou en visio ça
marche aussi ça marche même en visio sur
plusieurs personnes en même temps je dis
pas trop faire ça je dis que c'est
possible
la mécanique je vais vous faire voir les
deux tours je vais d'abord les faire à
loïc comme ça vous allez pouvoir voir un
petit peu l'impact le deuxième celui qui
vise à blanc physio vous pourrez faire
en même temps que loïc et après on
passera aux explications de ces deux
adaptations de tours dont je vous ai
parlé alors évidemment c'est tour la
détour de mentalisme répéter bien et
entraînez-vous bien avant si vous leur
faites telle qu'elle vous concentrer sur
le truc et c'est vraiment dommage en
fait quand vous faites un tour à
quelqu'un le moins important c'est le
truc c'est ce qui fait que ça fonctionne
en fait ça c'est juste le la mécanique
mais ce qui est important c'est notre
manière de le présenter de le faire
vivre de le commencer de le terminer
donc concentré vous là dessus pour faire
vivre une vraie expérience à la personne
à qui vous présenterez ça dans la vraie
vie ou en virtuel et en toute amitié ou
plus si affinités
bah ouais c'est peut-être n'a pas vu le
générique mais en fait c'est toi qui l'a
fait dans le générique est marquée de la
vidéo elle est en partenariat avec foot
ce qu'est une application de rencontre
et en plus c'est toi qui m'a demandé de
faire des tours pour des délits du coup
ça se tient
ok donc cette vidéo et en partenariat
avec roots routes c'est une application
de rencontre rencontre au sens très
large du terme vous allez voir avec un
concept ça rencontrer des gens qui ont
les mêmes envies que vous et les mêmes
objectifs que vous les mêmes objectifs
de rencontre en gros est ce que vous
recherchez une relation sérieuse ou
juste prendre un verre comme ça en toute
amitié ou alors une rencontre éphémère
pour ce soir parce qu'apparemment c'est
très urgent ou une relation non sérieuse
et en fait ce genre d'objectif de
rencontre c'est un peu compliqué de le
dire avec des mots donc eux ils ont
inventé un code avec des fruits cerise
c'est pour trouver sa moitié parce que
il ya deux cerises sur le petit enfin
bon on a compris raisin c'est pour
prendre un verre de vin sans se prendre
la grappe
on aime les jeux de mots laids
on adore pastèque c'est pour des câlins
récurrents sans pépin et pêche pour une
envie de pêcher pas compris je vais vous
montrer d'interface j'ai dû m'inscrire
je suis donc fait beau point com et moi
j'ai mis pour un verre de vin sans se
prendre la grappe hashtag pas de coups
d'un soir l'application est sympa aller
assez fun il suffit de soi ip pour
sélectionner des personnes qui
correspondent à notre mood aulas je sais
pas ce que j'ai fait oui voilà comme ça
c'est mieux
voilà bah moi comme c'est pour prendre
un verre de vin bien je peux soit il
fait tout le monde en fait vers la
droite il ya pas tant besoin de
sélection et comme entamer la discussion
ben c'est pas toujours simple ils ont
créé un truc qui s'appelle les questions
juteuse pour éviter le salut ça va qui
est toujours un peu mal les enfants et
donc les questions juteuse ben en fait
on choisit une des questions qui propose
on y répond et ça lance la discussion
sans pression sans pression les fruits
tu seras tu là ok maintenant que là vous
mais un lien en descriptions pour
télécharger l'application froots merci à
eux pour ce partenariat sur cette chaîne
youtube qui nous qui nous rapproche un
petit peu du casse-tête ultime
vous savez de quoi je parle et ne
cherchez pas mon compte je n'ai pas mis
mon vrai nom et c'est un conte
temporaire maintenant on passe donc au 2
tour d'abord le tour en physique après
le tour en visio que vous allez pouvoir
faire en même temps et après les
explications
j'en appelle à mon influenceurs le
regarde donc loïc oui imaginons que nous
sommes en plein deuil tu es je veux
faire un tour à l'air de covin je te
fais je veux te faire un tour mais je
veux pas te faire un tour en mode gros
rooney qui veulent impressionner
je veux faire un sujet de discussion une
petite expérience un petit truc tu vois
de ma fenêtre
tétreault dans le truc rires non c'est
que c'est plus en mode
tiens moi je m'intéresse à la
psychologie ali 10e mismo mentalist ça
tu connais moi super qui connaissent
bien les cartes abonnés je vous
recommande pas pour le nom maintenant
parce que les bars sont pas rouvert donc
on est juste intéressant mais tu m'as on
notre propre taille exacte exactement
donc en fait c'est du coup c'est un tour
que j'ai toujours sur moi ok et que
j'aime bien faire parce que j'aime bien
la mentalité en fait j'ai quatre cartes
quatre petites quatre essais car c'est
pas n'importe lesquels c'est l'as de
coeur
l'as de carreau l'as de trèfle et l'as
de pique
tu veux le voir non tu peux le garantir
ok ça c'est les 4 as en fait je vais les
mélanger pour quoi que tu saches dans
quel ordre ils sont je vais les mettre
là et je vais t'expliquer ça dure
vraiment qu'une seconde c'est un petit
truc psychologique d'ailleurs je serais
curieux de voir si ça marche ou pas sur
toi parce que je sais c'est un challenge
pour moi je vais mettre les quatre
cartes là comme ça et le pont faire un
chemin de toi jusqu'à moi c'est un peu
comme une connexion mental
connaissez vous serez tu choisis une des
cartes celle que tu veux mais attention
on choisit bien parce que tu choisiras
vraiment qu'une carte et ce sera terminé
choisissez-le que tu veux je suis celle
ci créée elle pas elle c cnet et pas
elle c'est sûr sûr je suis sur gmail
tu penses que c'est à las de quoi faire
je pense que c'est l'hadopi pense que
c'est l'as de pique du joli te dis c'est
beaucoup c'est marrant parce que ça
montre ton côté intuitif et moi je
m'attendais un peu à cette situation et
je ne te cache pas que derrière l'
enveloppe j'avais écrit quelque chose
j'avais écrit je savais que tu prendrais
l'as de pique
tu vois le mentalisme c'est ça du coup
c'est de se dire est ce que moi j'avais
prévu à l'avancé
est-ce que c'est ton intuition qui est
très forte ou est ce que le vieux port
que manière ou d'une autre si kolo gicm
à choisir cette carte là en particulier
et si tu veux on peut en parler c'est
peut être notre sujet de discussion mais
l'heure la psychologie je sais très fort
mais me dit c'était trop fort et je dois
la personne n'a pu lui parler après la
fed cup
mais après ça peut faire le sujet de
discussion en vrai eh bien ça c'était le
premier ça tu m j'adore tu le ferais tu
as besoin de 4 à ces d'une enveloppe et
pour le reste je vous explique ça tout à
l'heure après le deuxième tour vous êtes
ici vous êtes ici bonjour oui pour le
deuxième tour
donc on pourrait le faire en visio on
pourrait même le faire au téléphone en
vrai c'est un truc d'ailleurs qui a été
créé pour être fait à la radio mada
d'elle ouais ouais ouais donc je me dis
là ça correspond bien à la contrainte
que tu m'as dit faire un tour en visio
parce que si tu peux le faire au
téléphone et tu peux le faire en visio
et c'est ça qui est bon à plein de
personnes en même temps
donc vous vous allez faire en même temps
que l'oit d'abord vous pouvez mettre
pause si vous voulez pour sortir trois
quatre cinq ou six pièces de monnaie peu
importe les valeurs toi j'étais préparé
des pièces derrière tu en prends autant
que tu veux au moins 3 minimum jusqu'à 6
à partir de maintenant je vais me
retourner pour pas savoir ce que tu fais
ouais 3,4 en vrai c'est bien préciser je
suis très étonné qu'il sent by amazon
ec2 c'est bon ok bah tu déposes devant
toi toutes celles que tu utilises donc
trois quatre cinq ou six pièces et tu
l'aimés pile vers le haut le côté pile
vers le haut et on fasse vers le bas
pour ceux qui ne savent pas en surf ou
que j'entends trop tard j'entends pas le
temps de 10 ans a eu donc c'est pas
grave le côté pile d'une pièce c'est
celui ci vous le voyez à l'écran
c'est là où il ya le chiffre en général
et le côté face vous le voyez à l'écran
maintenant c'est là en général il ya une
face mais ça peut être aussi le dessin
d'un monument en tout cas c est ca c'est
un dessin c'est une représentation donc
le côté où il ya la phase vous mettez
face contre la table est donc en hausse
celui que vous voyez c'est le côté pile
c'est le cas pour toi le 8 août et côté
pile tout est codé fils ok super tu vas
retourner deux pièces si tu veux donc en
gros vous c'est pareil vous retourner
deux pièces si vous voulez ou pas pas
une c2 ou 0 à l'effet le hoodie moi
quand tu es prêt pour la suite
peut-être tu fais ça mange si vous aviez
plus de trois pièces
vous pouvez encore retourné deux autres
pièces face vers le haut
si vous voulez c'est pas obligatoire
encore une fois allez-y faites le si
vous le souhaitez loïc toi tu es prêt
pour la suite ce sera ok donc à partir
de maintenant loïc comme vous chez vous
vous avez 0 2 ou 4 pièces
côté face et le reste côté pile c'est
bien le cas
todd bon ok là maintenant c'est un peu
toi qui l'a décidée jusqu'à combien de
temps on va faire la prochaine action et
vous vous allez suivre loïc parce que je
ne vous entends pas dans l'espace
commentaire est ce que tu veux retourner
une pièce n'importe laquelle
oui alors vas-y retourne une pièce celle
que tu veux ok c'est fait ok maintenant
est ce que tu veux retourner encore une
pièce peut-être même là même où une
autre alors vas-y fais-le est ce que tu
veux retourner encore une pièce
peut-être là même où non non ok donc on
s'arrête vous avez fait comme loïc vous
avez retourné deux pièces ou peut-être
deux fois la même pièce mais vous avez
fait comme lui là je vous demandais un
truc c'est votre libre arbitre qui
rentrent en jeu vous allez choisir dans
votre tête l'une des pièces et vous me
dites que c'est fait monsieur eric
defert ok vous retourner cette pièce et
vous aussi chez vous vous avez choisi
une pièce et vous retournez cette pièce
était votre librairie on arrive à la
dernière étape vous informe que moi mon
but c'est que vous finissiez surface on
est en train de faire un pile ou face
mental je le même pas dû au départ
j'aurais dû le dire au départ on fait un
pile ou face au mental et mon but du jeu
c'est qu'à la fin vouziers face vous
allez voir ce que je veux dire tu
retiens ce que vient dire loïc la face
avec ta main gauche loïc et vous aussi
avec votre main gauche vous recouvrez
l'une des pièces c'est la pièce dont se
servira pour la fin pour le pile ou face
final donc tu recouvre l'une des pièces
avec ta main gauche c'est cette peur
c'est fait vous aussi chez vous au quai
et avec ta main droite
tu va éliminer toutes les pièces qui
sont côté pile donc vous aussi toutes
les pièces qui sont côté pile voulait
virer c'est tout
je me dis quand c'est bon pour la suite
c'est bon ok il vous reste peut-être des
pièces peut-être il vous reste plus s'il
vous reste des pièces elles sont
forcément côté face évidemment et je ne
compte pas la pièce qui sur votre main
bien sûr votre main droite va éliminer
une par une des pièces côté face mais à
chaque fois que vous enlevez une pièce
qu'est côté face vous retournez la pièce
qui est sous votre main en gros si vous
reste une pièce vous retourner une fois
la pièce qui s'ouvre demain s'il vous
reste deux pièces vous retourner deux
fois la pièce qui vous sous vêtements
etc etc
est ce que c'est à peu près clair ou pas
comme consigne loïc
moi ok je vis mais et faites le aussi
chez vous on s'y met tous ensemble on y
va les prochains lieux qui fait c'est
assez terminée c'est un jeune ado on est
bien d'accord qu'il ne vous reste plus
qu'une seule pièce c'est celle qui est
sous votre maintenant à mouvoir
maintenant je parle à un souche par la
bouche et vous oui vous tous d'accord
avec toi ok et tu te souviens du but de
mon jeu c'était que tu es une pièce
celle du pile ou face et que je tombe
surface c'est ça mon but ultime
et bien je vous propose à tous de
relever votre main est de constater que
vous êtes surface actuellement s'efface
un petit coup de pression avec jj crime
le cfa ce exact et alors ce qui se passe
c'est que vraiment chez eux aussi par le
nombre de pièces etc
vous êtes tous tombés sur place alors
que pourtant souvenez vous quand je vous
ai dit vous allez choisir une pièce
maintenant c'est votre libre arbitre et
la retourner
imaginez si vous aviez choisi d'autres
pièces que celle là ça ne se serait pas
passé par lens 8
mais je pense monsieur c'était vraiment
un mental
oui mais voilà ça c'est un truc que tu
peux faire un peu de personnes en même
temps en visio au téléphone je trouve
c'est un petit peu rigolo parce que se
situe le cd objets du quotidien et vous
c'est cool merci loïc lagarde
au revoir et du court on road est resté
pas ou comme des deux soit beau je
souhaite voir this way le soir
[Musique]
explication du tour numéro un du coup
tient une ré adaptation d'un classique
de l'illusionnisme et du mentalisme en
tout cas ça utilise un des procédés qui
peut être parfois utilisé encore une
fois ne vous concentrer pas sur ce truc
envoyer des tours de d'illusionnisme de
mentalisme il ya 99 99% de chances que
ce soit passa donc n'essayez pas
d'extrapoler par contre ça va vous
servir à faire cet effet encore une fois
ne vous concentrer pas sur le truc
concentrez-vous sur l'expérience en
mêmes souvenez vous de la réaction de
loïc c'est ça qui est intéressant en
fait et ça vient non pas du tour en
lui-même mais de tout ce qui allait
autour du tour pour ça vous allez avoir
besoin d'une enveloppe
donc de quatre cartes à jouer moi j'ai
pris des 4 as mais il ya un truc si vous
en vrai si vous faites inde est un des
hits avec foot vous pourriez très bien
prendre des cartes blanches ou des bouts
de carton pas forcément des cartes à
jouer on s'en fiche
et sur ces quatre cartons mettre les
quatre fruits de frites les cerises la
grappe de raisin la pastèque et la pêche
et faire ce truc là et cette prédiction
va dire avec les fruits ça peut être
coup d'envoi quoi pour voir si on a le
même moule
je regardais loïc pour une validation tu
vois de ces tig et là incroyable donc
une petite enveloppe
quatre cartes à jouer moi j'ai pris
d'assaut deux carreaux l'as de pique et
donc l'as de coeur j'ai un petit peu mal
fait mon truc d'ailleurs et je vais vous
faire voir vous allez pouvoir améliorer
ça en gros voici la préparation sur l'as
de coeur il ya un truc que vous n'avez
pas eu mais il ya écrit je savais que tu
prendrais l'as de coeur vous commencez à
voir où je veux en venir
il ya une préparation pour chacune des
cartes j'aurais pas dû le marquer autant
à gauche je vous montre pourquoi parce
que si je n'avais pas écrit autant à
gauche j'aurais pu éventail et les
cartes un peu comme ça vous devez le
voir là sur eux sur le plan qui est de
mon épaule j'aurais dû écrire un peu
plus dans cette zone là pour pouvoir
éventail et de manière naturelle là j'ai
été obligé de sortir l'écart très
lentement et de faire comme ça là ça
aurait été plus intéressant donc
derrière l' enveloppe vous avez vu c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec loïc vous
écrivez je savais que tu prendrais l'as
de pique mais il ya un dernier truc dans
l' enveloppe qui reste un carton un
carton que j'ai mis au départ avec loïc
jamais vu sur lesquels il y a écrit je
savais que tu prendrais l'as de trèfle
car oui dit oui mais l'as de carreau du
coup eh bien ça tombe bien ce carton à
deux côtés comme tous les cartons il ya
marqué je sais que tu prendrais l'as de
carreau en faisant attention que lancre
ne pénètre pas c'est un carton un petit
peu rigide donc j'ai tout ça qui est
préparé de ce côté là j'ai trèfle épique
et je sais que caro du coup c'est de
l'autre côté et que le coeur est
derrière cette carte
ensuite on rajoute un truc donc vous
avez parlé en 2016 sur cette chaîne sur
les forçages psychologique d'un point de
vue général et dans l'es10 ionis mme
qu'il y avait de fortes chances alors ça
pas été quantifiée manière très
scientifique mais il y avait de fortes
chances que si on crée un chemin avec
les quatre objets identiques et se
passer de la même manière entre deux
personnes et qu'on dise
choisi l'un des objets la personne
choisissent le troisième pourquoi parce
que notre cerveau a l'impression que
choisir les extrêmes c'est un peu grillé
un peu facile donc il va se concentrer
sur les deux autres et dans la grande
majorité des cas les personnes
choisissent le plus loin d'eux comme si
c'était plus compliqué où le deuxième
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec avec loïck
nous on a la plus belle façon de le
faire qui est placé sur le troisième
donc c'est à dire j'ai me l'as de coeur
en 3d on sait que le deuxième il peut
être sympa aussi
donc j'ai mis en pic parce que c'est le
plus joli aussi de juste retourner pour
moi si on peut éviter d'utiliser le
carton c'est quand même un peu plus
stylé donc le moment où je vais mélanger
en fait je sais toujours où j'en suis là
par exemple je sais que j'ai bien piqué
coeur qui sont au bon endroit
donc ça c'est à vous le suivre avec les
yeux ou est ce que c'est si la personne
choisie la carte qui est là donc ces
pics comme tout à l'heure avec loïc et
bien vous faites comme j'ai fait avec
loïc elle juste à retourner
l'enveloppent est ce un match des
rouches ellaone ça bug
si la personne elle soit
10 celle-ci du coup qu'est notre voeu le
trouve le plus intéressant et le plus
probable alors vous la retourne et pas
tout de suite
le truc qui coule à faire si vous dites
ok c'est le site assure donc je pas
celle ci sert l'as de carreau pas celle
ci donc l'as de pique pas celle ci à
l'as de trèfle
c'est donc l'as de coeur qui est a
choisi j'étais tellement sûre que tu
allais que choisir que j'avais écrit
dessus et là vous fait voir je trouve
que ça marche bien
maintenant dans les très rares caf ou la
personnel choisisse carreaux ou trèfle
si elle choisit on va commencer par
caraux vous prenez l enveloppe et vous
dit à l'intérieur de l'envelope j'avais
laissé un carton et regarde y'a marqué
je savais que tu prendrais baisse de 40
points
fin de l'histoire et si elle a choisi
l'as de trèfle
voici ce que je vous recommande de faire
est choisie s de 13 vous dites l'as de
trèfle vous prenez l'enveloppent en même
temps est uni tiens c'est marrant
donc là vous voyez de mon côté avec l'as
de trèfle j'ai caché les écritures mais
vous ça va vite hein vous dit tiens
c'est marrant parce que regarder à
l'intérieur de l'enveloppé là vous
baissez maintenant une fois de ses
cachets j'avais un carton et sur ce
carton il ya marqué je savais que tu
prendrais l'as de trèfle
voilà comme ça c'est le 4 possibilités
sont couvertes et puis une fois que le
tour est terminé vous remettez surtout
dedans
et peu importe la situation vous ranger
bien tout en mettant l'as de coeur
derrière pour pas pour être sûr de pas
faire un truc qui s'appelle flashé en
magis d'ailleurs qu'on voit qu'il y
avait quelque chose si la personne n'a
pas vu et vous remettez ça paraît dans
votre enveloppe mais de votre côté pour
pas qu'on voit les écritures etc vous
pouvez même le remettre dans votre poche
et enchaîner un deuxième but parce que
c'est déjà prêt
alors le deuxième tour faut rendre à
césar ce qui est à césar c'est plus
qu'une adaptation c'est vraiment le tour
qu'a créé juan tamariz en 2003 il était
à la radio toutes les semaines dans nos
ce mot stadiers c'était une émission
radiophonique et toutes les semaines il
faisait un tour à distance aux auditeurs
on remonte à maryse c'est une légende
vivante dans le milieu de la magie
je vais vous mettre des vidéos en lien
dans la description si j'oublie de le
faire vous me le dites dans les
commentaires vers des numéros qu'il a
fait quand il est venu en france au plus
grand cabaret du monde par exemple c'est
vraiment un personnage c'est vraiment un
univers les tours il s'en fout mais lui
il est un personnage vraiment fou
regardez ça ça vaut vraiment le coup
il pour que ça marche il faut que la
personne elles prennent trois quatre
cinq ou six pièces mais vous pouvez
simplement dire prenez tous trois pièces
ou à la personne qui en visio prend
trois pièces ou prend 4 pièces vous
pouvez donner le chiffre dès le départ
faut qu'à mettre toutes les pièces côté
pile en haut pour qu'on sache d'où sa
part on va dire l'étape une dont moi je
prends trois pièces file vers le haut
ensuite étape 2 à la le droit ou pas de
retourner deux pièces nous on va
retourner deux pièces qui vont être
cotés face elle le fait ou pas ça c'est
l'étape deux étapes une le nombre de
pièces file vers le haut et étape 2 elle
retourne deux pièces ou pas et vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de savoir c'est ça qui
est hyper miraculé dans ce genre de tour
l'étape 2 c'était ça étape 3 la personne
va retourner autant de fois qu'elle veut
le nombre de pièces qu'elle veut et ça
peut être la même pièce ou une autre
pièce etc
comme vous l'avez vu c'était loïc qui
décide et ça c'est hyper intéressant
parce que vous pouvez très bien lui
demander de lancer un dé et vous dites
c'est quoi le résultat c'est ça un coq
et donc tu vas retourner cinq fois les
pièces celles que tu veux ça peut le
plusieurs fois la même etc vous pouvez
le faire comme ça c'est hyper
intéressant
la seule chose à retenir c'est qu'il
faut que ce soit un nombre de fois un
père pour que ça fonctionne donc si
c'est un nombre de fois père vous allez
faire comme moi tout à l'heure et dirait
maintenant concentre toi sur une pièce
hockey et vas-y retourne là en gros vous
rajoutez la dernière fois il faut que ce
soit un père donc nous on va dire
imaginons qu'à personnage est le d elle
tombe sur quatre elle retourne une fois
deux fois trois fois et quatre fois
hélas
la vue je retournais deux fois la même
pièce là vous vous intervenez après en
disant ok c'est bon ok concentre toi sur
une pièce tout cela retourne là et comme
ça tu sais que ça fait 5 et ça a été un
nombre de fois un père donc ça c'était
l'étape 3 étape 4
elle met la main gauche sur l'une des
pièces et elle enlève toutes les pièces
qui sont côté pile nous on n'a pas de
pièce côté pile donc on touche à rien
pour le moment
et enfin la dernière étape à chaque fois
qu'il ya des relèves l'une des pièces
qui est côté face elle doit retourner la
pièce qui se joue sam à une fois donc
moi j'ai deux pièces une et deux j'ai
donc retourné deux fois et donc la pièce
qui était sous ma main et côté face et
là vous dites oui mais pourquoi ça
marche pas je vous invite à y réfléchir
mais c'est de la pure logique
mathématique qui est derrière et ce qui
est fascinant c'est d'avoir créé ce tour
et pour ça je veux des gros gégé juan
tamariz travail espace commentaires
d'ailleurs dit moi ce que ça vous a fait
quand ça a marché chez vous parce que si
ça n'a pas marché s'il me dit que ça n'a
pas marché c'est pas les maths qui se
sont trompés c'est vous un moment donné
que qu'il n'y avait pas fait ce qui
était dit je vous faire un cap très
simple 1 on met trois quatre cinq ou six
pièces côté pile en l'air de la personne
retourne deux pièces face en l'air ou
pas
3 elle retourne autant de fois qu'elle
veut les pièces qu'elle veut ok 3 10 6
et un nombre de fois père vous rajoutez
une fois vous même 4 elle met la main
sur l'une des pièces et le bougera plus
c'est la pièce de la faim oubliez pas
d'annoncé l'enjeu qui est de finir
surface et que c'est un pile ou face
virtuel 5
elle enlève toutes les pièces qui sont
pile encore visibles et enfin si ces
dernières à chaque fois qu'elle enlève
une pièce qui efface elle doit retourner
la pièce qui est sous sa main gauche
voilà pour l'explication évidemment
oubliez pas de bien répéter surtout pour
le deuxième tour mais même pour le
premier aussi parce que ça paraît simple
maintenant que vous connaissez le truc
mais encore une fois une fois que vous
l'aviez vu si c'est fluide c'est
bluffant
donc il faut bien connaître toutes les
étapes pour pas alterner les étapes avec
des gros et maintenant ce qu'on va faire
il faut que ça paraisse fluide naturel
comme si ses limites comme si c'était
improvisé
ça doit être le truc il doit être un
prétexte à quelque chose de plus grand
qui fait rêver qui est hyper agréable
merci encore une fois à foot d'avoir été
partenaire de cette vidéo je vous mets
le lien de l'application la description
l'application est gratuite vous pouvez
la télécharger vous inscrire dessus et
puis n'oubliez pas mettre le maoût que
vous voulez pour rencontrer les gens
aussi qui sont dans le même mode
justement si la vidéo vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de lalique et si vous ne
connaissez pas je m'appelle fabien
olicard vous pouvez vous abonner juste
là activer la cloche c'est important et
là je vous mets deux autres vidéos pour
poursuivre un petit peu cette vidéo
c'est sur la définition du mentalisme et
j'ai invité plein de copains mentalist
pour en parler comme ça ça peut vous
renseigner sur ce que c'est et lorsque
ça n'est pas hélas c'est une vidéo d'un
autre tour de mentalisme je pense que ça
va vous plaire de faire ça donc regarder
ça aussi c'est assez malin à très
bientôt chat